consider the square root of eight
it's an irrational number since all the
three conditions are satisfied
let's review the three conditions
it has an order which is a natural
number greater than 1
the base is a positive rational number
and it's an irrational root which means
the value of root 8 is irrational
let's reduce the base to its prime
factors
it will equal root of 2 times 2 times 2.
since we are calculating the square root
we can take a pair of same numbers and
take one number out from the pair
here we make a pair of the number 2
taking 1 2 outside we write it as 2 root
2.
so root of 8 can also be written as 2
root 2.
now look at this 2 root 2.
a rational number is multiplied with an
irrational number
but the result is still irrational
this is called a mixed third
it's of the form k
nth root of a
where k is a rational number
and k does not equal plus or minus 1.
if k is 1 then it's as good as not
multiplying the irrational number with
anything
and nth root of a has to be absurd
remember k has to be a rational number
and this has to be irrational
and k cannot be equal to plus or minus
1.
k is also referred to as the rational
factor
now here's another irrational number
cube root of nine
is there a k here
yes it's one
this is actually one multiplied by cube
root of nine
this is called a pure third
it is of the form k
nth root of a where k is equal to plus
or minus 1.
but wait observe the first example
root 8
for root 8 k is equal to 1
it's of this form
hence it's a pursuit
so we wrote a pure third as a mixed
third
similarly this mixed third two root two
can be written as root eight
so we should know that sometimes pure
search can be written as mixers and vice
versa
but it's important to know that it does
not hold good always
look at the second example for instance
cube root of nine reducing nine to its
prime factors we can write this as cube
root of three times three
but we cannot reduce it further and
that's why it's only a pure third
so these are the two types of surges
mixed third in which k is a rational
number but does not equal plus or minus
1 and a pure third in which k equals
plus or minus 1.
and also keep in mind that whatever be
the value of k this will be a mixed or a
pure third only if nth root of a is a
third
if we have something like 3 root 16 we
cannot call it a mixed third since root
16 itself is not absurd